pénale le deuxième procès de patrick
dils touche à sa fin de ma le verdict
sera rendu aujourd'hui la mère de
l'accusé à dialoguer avec son fils qui
hier a eu des difficultés à expliquer
pourquoi il n'avait pas tué les deux
enfants
clément weill-raynal salah à granby
pourquoi patrick dils s'il est innocent
avait il avoué il ya quinze ans le
meurtre de cyril et alexandre 7 jours
d'audience et 1 très longue
interrogatoire hier de l'accusé n'ont
pas permis de répondre à la question les
policiers m'avait suggéré des aveux a
simplement déclaré patrick dils dont la
personnalité demeure un mystère
à l'époque 82 parlait pas beaucoup voici
n'y a presque pas là il a parlé mais
c'était largement passé
pour convaincre la cour j'espère y ait
davantage de
patrick on est amis on sait périlleuse
pas beaucoup on parle pas alors il a
parlé comme il a pu avec ses tripes car
malgré tout si aujourd'hui après 15 ans
et après la révision qui est camille
story il ne peut quasiment toujours pas
s'expliqué très clairement sur le
pourquoi les avez la réputation
j'imagine ce que ça pouvait être il ya
quinze ans c'est donc un garçon qui ne
pouvaient pas communiquer et bien qu'il
ait grandi en prison qu'il ait pris une
maturité les experts sont d'accord qui a
toujours beaucoup de mal n'ont pas
communiqué mais a communiqué ses
impressions
même si à l'époque le jeune homme
n'avait que 16 ans ses aveux continuent
de peser dans le dossier de l'accusation
patrick dils avait expliqué en détails
aux policiers puis au juge d'instruction
comment ils avaient massacré à coups de
pierres les deux enfants dont les corps
avaient été retrouvés le long de cette
voie ferrée lors de la reconstitution
il avait répété les gestes ni mais le
double crime dont il est accusé
sans protester de son innocence on n'a
pas d'explication on n'a pas
d'explication
alors on est dans une situation dure
pour la bêtise il faut le reconnaître
parce que là et qu'on aborde les faits
dès qu'on aborde le dossier
on s'aperçoit que ces déclarations la
semaine terrible terrible au niveau des
fai des déclarations des éléments et
puis terrible si au niveau des détails
qui sont de belles si patrick dils est
innocent qui donc est le coupable peut
être le tueur en série francis heaulme
présents sur les lieux du crime
mais l'audition de francis heaulme lors
du procès n'a pas permis d'en savoir
plus c'est donc dans cette salle que
tout va se jouer demain soir à l'issue
du réquisitoire de l'avocat général et
des plaidoiries de la défense patrick
dils dans ce box écoutera les jurés de
la cour d'assises de la marne prononcer
leur verdict coupable ou innocent ça à
new york